a common challenge for improvement teams
is identifying what changes you can test
to improve a processor problem one great
method to help you break down ideas as a
tool known as a cause and effect diagram
you may have also heard of this tool
referred to as an Ishikawa diagram
attributed to its creator kuru Ishikawa
or a fishbone diagram because of the
resemblance to the bones of a fish to
create a cause and effect diagram right
the effect in a box on the right hand
side of the page so let's imagine we're
working on improving hand washing all
right then draw a horizontal line across
the page
decide on a few categories or causes for
the problem useful categories of causes
in a classic fish bone diagram include
people methods materials equipment and
environment then we can draw a diagonal
line to each of these and these are the
actually the the bones of the fish and
hence its name the process of
categorizing potential causes may be
very useful to help you to break down a
complex problem and focus in on it from
various perspectives so as you're
looking at each of the categories you
want to generate a list of causes in
this example people might include
clinical staff
right it also might include a
non-clinical staff I'll just put them as
just other staffers it might include the
methods how do you actually wash your
hands I'll say wash process it could be
the materials or using the right kind of
soap or is it dry out your hand so we'll
think about the soap it could be the
equipment like the dispenser it's an
easy dispenser to use does it give you
the right amount or maybe it's the
environment where is the dispenser
location is it near the process of care
identify the causes by you know asking
why with people that are closest to the
process until you've reached a useful
level of detail that is when the cause
is specific enough to be able to test a
change and to measure its effects
sometimes I like to describe this for
folks that have children as the
five-year-old method you know if you
ever had a kid they ask you why five
times constantly until they get to the
root of the problem and you're doing the
same thing here
you